[Music]
my name is Brady diva I'm a partner in
our PwC practice in Australia I've got a
colleague here who's going to be
co-presenting with me today at News to
the directory now PwC Australia practice
um we're really excited today to be
given this opportunity to talk to you
all and present here at the Google next
conference about a solution that was
really spawned off of the same
conference nine months ago where we like
you guys were sitting Peter we see were
you know ed and I'm particularly were
very lucky and fortunate to have an
invite to this same conference and we're
sitting in the audience looking at a
couple of solutions platform Don JCP and
using some of the ml and OCR
technologies that Google has for some
accounting problems olds and we're
sitting there as tacks guys thinking gee
how good would that be if we could take
it a slight step further and start to
solve on top of the accounting fix some
of the bugbears that we see in our day
to day lives as advisors and also some
of our clients from a tax calculation
and classification perspective in
systems and so that was really where we
started so we started as a as an idea as
a thought bubble nine months ago in July
literally the next day we're lucky
enough to have some of our Google
partners catch up with us and we were
able to then sit down and walk through
some of the ideas and we were really
really fortunate that Google kind of
bought in really really early into this
opportunity and so a very very short but
intense journey kind of started in July
last year to get us to where we are
today
so really really excited to be able to
show you where we've got to so what
we're going to do today is just spend a
few moments if okay around the business
problem that this technology is aiming
to solve conscious given that we're in
the United States the use case that
we're talking about here is indirect tax
value-added taxes and GST right which is
largely a non-us tax so I might just
spend a little bit of time if ok with
you all just to walk through
the basics of what the business problem
is in the tax problem that this solution
is trying to solve
well then I'll then how to cross to my
colleague ed and Ed will give us a live
demonstration of the solution in action
it has just come out of POC phase in
Australia we're really excited about the
initial results and super keen to show
you what it looks like then we'll talk a
little bit about development roadmap
given that you know we are just out of
POC and we have got big plans for this
so we'll talk a little bit about that
how we're planning to adapt it in
certain jurisdictions given the
differences in in in tax and business
problems across the world and then we'll
spend a little bit of time on some of
the future use cases and some of the
questions that our clients have already
started to ask us around what the
solution could potentially do outside of
tax and then hopefully if we can state a
time and I know Australians are
notorious for waffling and talking if we
can keep the time we'll make sure we've
got a few minutes at the end for some
Q&A
and when we do - the Q&A you know the
ask that will we'll just have of yours
if you could just stand up and maybe
just just take it microphone in there in
the aisle here to talk okay so the tool
is called zip line there's a story
behind the name and some of my Google
Australia colleagues in the front seats
here will know I'll give you the
official reason why we're calling it a
zip line it is a no CRNA ni a combined
solution the reason why we've called it
zip line and has got a meaning is
because we see this piece of technology
is solving or bridging a gap that has
existed and has been a bugbear in in my
world as an indirect tax advisor my
clients world trying to cope with
indirect tax automation in systems
because it's the last area where there
is a manual process that can't until now
have been automated and we're really
excited to be able to say that we can
get this automated on the Accounts
Payable
side of of the tax ledger and so for
that reason because we're bridging this
gap we call it a zip line and then the
simple reason why the other reason so
it's got a double meaning the other
reason why it's a zip line is because
the p2p office and the Google office in
Sydney is literally separated by
hundred yards of water and it takes us
half an hour 45 minutes to get across
but if you had a zip line we'd be there
in two seconds so that was part of the
other reason so and so like I mentioned
so so this is this is an OCR AI tool ed
will talk about a bit about functionally
and technically how it works
I should just kv8 that by saying for all
that the the techies in the room
we aren't techies we're tax people we
know enough about the tech to be
dangerous what we've been really
fortunate to have in both of our
organizations in Google and in PwC is a
whole bunch of really really smart tech
people and engineers that can help us
bring this to life to solve the business
problem that we have but we will do our
best to answer any of the technological
questions around sort of functionally
how its set up and to the extent there
are any of those questions okay so the
business issue so va te and GST so
value-added tax
predominant tax on consumption in Europe
and in most of Latin America and in most
of Asia Pacific it's called Goods and
Services Tax GST ins in some of those
jurisdictions it's a little like sales
tax in the US except that it's two-sided
so not only do people so businesses that
sell goods and services have to collect
and pay tax to the authorities on the
things they sell so that is a feature of
the of the GST and VAT regime the
critical difference between g18 v80 and
sales tax however is that and this is
the two-sided nature of the tax is that
you as a business are also charged v80
and GST on the things that you buy so
it's a it's an input and an output
system the good news is for businesses
is that for the vast majority of the
purchases that businesses make the v8 e
or the GST can be reclaimed it can be
recovered as a refund from the Tax
Office's but this is subject to a couple
of key conditions and this is where the
manual problems have existed in our
world since you know the 1970s when the
tax was conceived by the French
the tea the two key conditions to be
able to get that GST or VA tea that's
been incurred on your purchases back
from the tax authorities one that it is
a specified business eligible purchase
under local VA tea in GST law right so
there's a legal requirement that you
need to meet and that's based on tax
rules and legislation that business and
tax legislation those tax rules are then
augmented or qualified by the type of
business that you are so there's a legal
question is it or isn't it recoverable
and then the second question is based on
the business type that I am as an
acquirer of services or goods how does
that impact will change my
recoverability of that tax so that's the
technical problem and in 150 countries
around the world those rules are all
different the second problem is a
document problem and I'm lucky enough to
kind of hear some of the the Q&A and the
interviews over in Moscone just before
we went live and one of the ladies was
talking about dark data and that's data
that is is trapped on a paper document
in an unstructured form and that's the
problem that we having v in the VA TV
world on purchases we need to be able to
identify that we hold a valid document
to support our claim so one we need to
make sure legal in terms of complying
with the law - we need to check that
against our business type and three
regardless of what goes into our system
we need to hold a valid document in a
specified form and so what that is meant
in terms of in terms of business process
is that typically v80 and GST on
purchases has been systemized to a
degree and that is effectively once the
data is input into the system okay so
when when a purchase is is made a Pio is
struck and an invoice is received either
a vendor invoice or an employee expense
there's a big piece here around employee
expenses thus if the data goes somebody
has to actually lift the data off those
invoices make a GST or v80 decision what
kind of expensive
is it recoverable and if it is
recoverable what code do I then apply to
the transaction as I'm posting that
transaction into the system okay once
the transactions in the system systems
are very very good at then automating
how the GST should then flow through the
accounts and then ultimately onto a
return so that you can claim it back
from from the from the regulator's so
that's what effectively we mean by a tax
engine up on the screen so tax engines
are really really good at running rules
based logic to identify and capture GST
or VA te but the key criterias that we
capture that data off off of those
source invoices and that old adage of
you know junk e'en and junk out is
really really true from a v18 GST
perspective on purchases so what we find
as we've talked about is a very manual
process across a number of our clients
across the world and that could be a
native Accounts Payable function that
sits on site it can be a BPO
you know an outsource function but there
is always inevitably some form of
document checking manual import and
process and what we see is it costs it
creates a lot of issues for our clients
the first issue is it costs money and
I've got to start up there from from sa
P conquer they estimated cost of EI t
world GST world there's around 20 min 20
billion US dollars of VAT in GST on
taxis on hotels on flights on meals that
just goes missing and the reason why it
goes missing is because one businesses
see those as these as low-cost purchases
they but they do add up over time
obviously given the given the number on
the screen to the employees often that
are making reimbursement claims need to
make those tax decisions off of the
invoices and three because of that the
risk of an employee selecting a wrong
tax code is simply too high so
businesses choose not to engage and
claim that GST back the second thing in
the vendor world so outside of the the
employee expense but in the vendor
purchases world we see a lot of problems
batik
in Australia around that manual process
risk on accounts payable and you know
some of the stats out of our Australian
Tax Office
actually show that almost 70% of errors
on the Accounts Payable side and this is
data collected across the whole of the
Australian taxpayer base are caused by
system and process deficiency so there's
risk that can go both ways you can i
over claim or under claim because of the
manual gap and then three efficiency
right so you're asking in this manual
world accounts payable and BPOs who
aren't often tax trained to make tax
decisions and process documents for tax
purposes and that takes time and effort
that can be redeployed to other more
value adding tasks in the business the
last thing that I just wanted to touch
on in terms of the current state and why
we saw this is a really key problem to
solve is that the v80 and the GST world
is undergoing a huge shift at the moment
which is driven by technology okay so as
it stands in the majority of the v80 in
GST world at the moment it's a
traditional tax compliance reporting
system and what I mean by that is
transactions occur in a period in a
month the month stops we've got 21 days
to then collate all of that data out of
our system put it onto a tax return and
file and in that 21 day period between
month end and when we need to file this
time for us to run checks to extract
reports to do reconciliations into file
returns right so we've got time to look
back over our data and check that it's
right the problem is where we're now
moving is to what what I call a
real-time reporting electronic filing
regime and this is no more pronounced
and in places like Spain where the
regulator now says we're doing away with
that that that returned traditional
process and we're replacing it and what
we're replacing it with is every four
days I want a direct upload out of your
source systems as a client and I want
your AR I want your AP I want your GL
and I'll work out how much tax you have
to pay and I'll do it every four days
and you have to pay it every four days
okay so you can see that
the mental shift from you know a time
lag between when a transaction occurs
and when we need to report and when we
need to collect and pay - now that'd be
much more compressed and the tax offices
across the world having a lot more of
your data than previously you gave okay
so for us what that means is it really
really enhances this importance of
getting those tax decisions right in the
system first time and so we things
applying does a lot of that we think we
think it fills that last mile between
invoice receipt from third party
suppliers from employees who want their
their expenses back into the system to
allow tax rules and classification to
work to get your data right in the
system at the time the transactions are
processed and I might just hand over to
Ed now just to give you a little bit
more overview in terms of in terms of in
terms of the solution and where we're at
both as a standalone offering but also
some of the exciting opportunities that
we're looking at at the moment in terms
of partnerships and integrations with
ERP providers and expense platforms like
SA P so for example where we're in the
middle of conversations right now with
sa P concur to have integration
capability to actually have this as a as
an ongoing sub process within your
employee expenses system similar also
for for the accounts payable modules in
the in the core RP providers so so at
the moment a standalone solution but
we're really really excited about what
integration looks like and having this
ingrained as a sub process for tax
inside of the ERP in the future
sure morning everybody we got the
solution overview on the left-hand side
as Brady mentioned I'm not a tech guy
either but I can talk you through
basically what the what the technology
stack is I think the key points are on
the right-hand side so what are we doing
we're extracting the data from the
underlying source invoices utilizing
Google's cloud vision API and we're also
using a machine learning base model to
take that OCR output and to classify the
fields on the invoice or the receipt as
Brady mission before we then have to
validate whether what's on that invoice
meets local requirements so there's a
set of tax rules which we've built in
from each local jurisdiction as to what
fields are and are not required part
three is where it starts getting really
interesting because having then taken
those data fields having applied the ml
logic to get the relevant data fields
categorized we can then run PwC
classification over what that expense
type is so Brady mentioned before
different expense types are capable of
different tax credits so the capability
we've built in here allows for an
expense type determination and
differentiation between the expense
that's been incurred where it's relevant
for for tax recovery and lastly we get a
validated tax reclaim amount per
transaction line-item so if there hasn't
been a booking in the underlying system
that will be the GST reclaim amount or
v80 if there has been then we can
reconcile the zip line output with the
underlying system output to the extent
that there's a difference that can be
investigated so if we look at the
solution itself I think the key point is
that we've got those two different
models so for invoices extraction we've
got an ml model that sits over the cloud
vision API data extraction we also use
the cloud translate capability where the
invoice is not in English and we have
that separate model for the
classification
in the bottom right hand corner of the
expense type so for those who are
interested the model that we're using is
a long short-term memory neural
recurrent neural network I think that I
think I've got my memory right there
jump in Before we jump into the demo I
think that's that's a really important
point in terms of those four gates in
terms of that that the business case
that we started to think about nine
months ago when we first saw some of
this technology in use so there are a
lot of OCR as you as many of you in the
room would know a lot of OCR providers
that look at expense posting data
extraction from instruction into
structured the thing that we really like
about this and particularly the Google
technology that sits behind it in the
vision API on there and the deep
learning models is that unlike a number
of other OCR providers which takes a
template or grid based approach to OCR
where we teach the machine to look for
things in certain quadrants of a
document the benefit of the of the
Google technology here is that because
of the deep learning model that is
behind it and the hundreds of thousands
of documents that have sat in the
training data set is that the tool keeps
looking no matter where the data is is
located on a document to get the thing
that we need okay so that's the first
thing that I really like about about the
about the Google tech and and and the
differentiator that it gives the second
thing which is where I think the
incremental value comes off some of the
existing OCR processes for tax is that
not only does it just extract for the
purposes of posting it extracts and
while it's extracting it applies smart
logic to work out whether the document
is valid from a tax perspective to solve
that that point we spoke about before
and then it also does things like pings
you know you know internet registers for
tax authorities to validate that this
that the seller is who they say they are
that their that their ABN or their VAT
IDs correct so they are genuinely
registered and that matters in a lot of
jurisdictions and it also validates the
GST calculations or the VAT calculations
so are we seeing a ten dollar GST amount
for a hundred dollar purchase in
Australia the vit rate is 10%
so it is doing a whole bunch of smart
calcs using the ml based on tax rules
and logic that PwC is co-created
together with Google to actually lift
the data and do smart things to it on
the invoice level so that's gate one
right then once we get through the
invoice validity phase we then kick it
into another airmail model which is a
tax engine which actually runs
categorization so looking at so for
example if we've acquired stools how is
how does the body of data that sits in
the ml model categorized stools for that
purposes office equipment so it'll say
stools equals office equipment and that
will then do the auto categorization
which then allows the standardization to
occur for it for a tax calculation rule
set to then do the rest of the job in
the system and so you know the smart
technology that Google has in vision API
and their deep learning models the
tensor flow models that sit behind the
tax rules engine augmented and
supplemented by PwC tax content for us
is where the magic happens in this and
we're really really keen to show you
kind of how this works
with a few real you know real life
scenarios but that I think is the key
differentiator between this POC and what
other OCR providers on expense side in
the market do today we actually add some
smart analysis at the time that the OCR
is scanning the invoices and
post-processing those invoices sorry no
this one so if you we move on to the
next process which outlines what the
business process actually is at the
moment if we have a look at the top line
here this is what's happening within the
expense management system so we've got
started going into the system
we've got typically an AP Clark or an
employee making those classification
decisions where zip line comes in is
that second line so as Brady mentioned
the tenta flow models the cloud vision
API the Translate API we're required
will kick in and that then that triggers
the automated process of that validation
classification and then tax credit
calculation which can then feed
automatically onto a tax return or in a
live reporting environment
directions in Saxony so with that I'll
jump into the demo and show you exactly
how it works excellent so you will
notice that the UI has not been designed
as a client facing UI at this point in
time this is an internal PwC UI we are
developing a client UI but for the
purpose of the proof-of-concept we kept
this as an internal one but certainly
our anchor clients are very interested
in the visualizations that we can take
from this process so the first step is
going to be to get the documents into
the system so here I'm going to select
five invoices we're going to upload
those invoices into the system you can
see that that happened very quickly
we are unconstrained by volume instead
of give you an example one of our anchor
clients has several hundred thousand
invoices again the power of the Google
tech allows for the OCR to happen in a
matter of milliseconds so we're
completely unconstrained by my data
upload we are working with partners such
as s AP and sa P concur on utilizing
their ap is to go direct into their
systems
because for bulk data extraction that
using the api's is most efficient that
said we also have developed RPI
solutions to allow for bulk extraction
of data where an API is not available so
those files have now been uploaded you
can see that we have each of them here
to the extent of file has been multiple
pages that's automatically split it into
individual pages we can now go in and
look at a particular invoice so here
we've got an Australian invoice it is a
valid tax invoice so we'll show you how
the OCR process has worked so the OCR
has identified each of the individual
text blocks on the invoice once it goes
through the tensorflow model and applies
the machine learning you'll see we have
small text here but you can see that
it's identified things like the vendor
name the vendor tax registration number
the date of the invoice description etc
on the right hand side we have all the
relevant fields for in this case an
Australian invoice and again given that
we had the content of the PWC global
network we know what fields are required
for what document type in every location
around the world with a BAC or GST
system so you'll see here that that
tensorflow model has taken each field
and identified whether the value exists
within that invoice so here we do have
the phrase tax invoice which is
requirement we've got the date total
amount GST amount included the vendors
tax registration number etc so as I said
before in a matter of milliseconds we've
taken an invoice it's been uploaded and
then ocr'd the EMA model applied and we
now have all the relevant fields
available for either input into the
underlying system or validation of the
underlying data input so all of those
invoices have now been uploaded and
we're then going to visualize that
through what we call the Swift dashboard
so the Swift dashboard is where that
stage 2 ml has happened so this is where
the expense classification and
validation is taking place so you see
here we've got some stats up top we've
got how many transactions have been
uploaded into the solution the total
value of transactions that's been
classified the total BAC spend on those
transactions and then the resulting BAC
flammable so going back to Brady's
earlier point on live reporting here we
can take an entire data set for a larger
organization and within a matter of
minutes it's gone through the process
being validated and it's producing a vit
claimable amount which can go on a
return or directly to the tax
authorities
we've got some visualization here over
the amounts the vit spend and the
categorizations and as I mentioned
before we're developing this further
with with clients for a client user
interface but what I want to do now is
just take you through what those five
invoices were and to show you how the
classification and validation process
has worked so I'm going to start with
one which is a valid invoice but is
foreign so a foreign invoice is not
going to be subject to reclaim in
Australia if we have a look here this is
an invoice from Singapore it's a hotel
invoice this would be a valid invoice if
it was being incurred by Singaporean
company in Singapore but here it's been
occurred incurred by an Australian so
it's not claimable within the Australian
GST system so if we click back into into
Swift we'll see here that it was a valid
invoice however it's been classified as
foreign it's listed the total amount
it's listed the VAT spent and here it's
made that tax calculation decision that
the tax payable is zero on the basis
that it's not local tax interestingly
enough there are a lot of cross-border
tax credit mechanisms so even though
it's not claimable within Australia we
can then report for potentially a
Singapore reclaim where the client will
be able to claim that seventy three
dollars back in a separate tax return we
move on to the next example and this is
the one that we really try and avoid
this is where we've got a local invoice
but it's not a valid invoice if we have
a look at this example this is an uber
receipt the value here is 83 dollars in
Australia we have a rule that anything
above eighty two dollars fifty requires
certain requirements that aren't
required under that threshold so one of
the requirements is it must have the
term tax invoice at the top you can see
here that the term invoice appears but
the term taxi invoice does not appear as
such when we look at how the solution
has prefilled these fields it is not
applied a value
for the tax invoice phrase appearing on
that basis when we go back into the
solution you can see that it's been
deemed to be invalid its domestic there
is an amount of tax on the invoice but
it's not claimable because we have an
invalid document these are the types of
documents that are really useful from a
management reporting perspective to then
inform the control and process
environment upstream about what type of
data and invoices is being provided by
either vendors or employees into the
relevant systems because here we've paid
tax out we do have an implicit right to
claim it if we have a valid document but
for whatever reason we don't hold that
document if we did we'd you get the tax
back this is a massive gap in our client
base where they're paying substantial
amounts of tax out but that but the
document is not valid the third example
is a valid one where there's no GST on
the underlying invoice so if we have a
look here this invoice formatting is
perfect it requires it has all the
required fields but if we have a look it
was international travel and therefore
there was no GST in the price so the
solution has classified that as a valid
invoice as a domestic invoice but with
no GST recovery because there was no GST
spend in the first place one of the
risks with previous solutions is that
when you have a category like airfare
which could potentially contain tax or
not depending on whether it's domestic
versus international travel
if you automatically assign a tax credit
calculation to that airfare category
that may have imputed a tax credit in
this case where there was no tax paid so
by going to the source document and
validating it we take out any risk that
the underlying classification of that
expense type account it may have been
incorrect and if I could just add so so
this is for us where the real value
occurs so I mentioned before around
systems having rule sets to calculate
GST we see time and time again the
system doing its job perfectly and what
I mean by that is when the code is hit
that says this is a tax reclaimer will
expense everything works the problem is
if you're leaving it to an employee or
an Accounts Payable clerk to rely on
that first decision to get the
categorization right then that's where
the risk occurs and so what this
solution does is it scans the source
document and works out from the source
document based on the ml model this is
behind what kind of expense it is and is
it classified as a recoverable expense
or a non recoverable expense so that gap
where you're relying on a non tax
trained person to make a tax call goes
away and that's where we see the rule
bit value year and as business processes
have become more and more outsourced and
more and more removed from the business
that's how the MIS classification is
having more and more often so I'll run
you through just the the last couple of
examples here I want to show you a
standard invoice it's the one we looked
at before so as I mentioned earlier on
all of the relevant requirements for a
valid tax invoice are here so the
solution has deemed the invoice to be
valid it's a domestic invoice it's
capable of full v80 or GST recovery
because here it's a hotel invoice that's
a valid business spend so you'll see
here that the bat spend has been
identified and the back claimable has
been identified as exactly the same
amount so this is where we would expect
the vast majority of our clients
invoices this category to fall into
where you do have a valid document and
your auto calculating the tax but to
brady's earlier point you're getting the
surety that on each and every occasion
that the system is working correctly
rather than applying a default rule and
the last one I want to show you is where
the real intelligent part of that second
ml model is coming in so this is where
we have an entertainment expense so here
we've got an invoice or a receipt from
from a restaurant the value shows that
it's not subsistence I may or may not
have participated in that event but like
it was a good one so here that logic
that's applied within the ml model of
looking at the vendor type of looking at
the spend the location
has been able to determine that rather
than being a general expense this is an
expense of an entertainment nature now
entertainment typically and most that
jurisdictions has a restricted recovery
because the tax office doesn't want you
to be able to go out and and have a
high-value lunch or dinner and claim all
the tax back so here we've identified
that it falls within that category it is
a valid document so when it comes to the
back claimable amount we've been able to
apply the relevant local rule for
restriction so the VA spend amount is
double what the VA see claimable amount
is because we only have a 50% right to
recovery of entertainment expenses this
again is one of those scenarios where if
you're an AP Clark or an individual
trying to do a classification in an
expense type which is not subject to
full recovery that gives very very
tricky so the m/l model that sits behind
this has been trained for years by PwC
to do expenses type classifications both
for indirect taxes corporate and other
taxes and so we're able to apply it here
to do that classification and we can use
the same expense classification
methodology in any country that has a
differentiation on tax credit of
different expense types incurred so what
we've done here in in Australia is
really just categorize down to what we
would call the lowest common denominator
from a GST recovery perspective and we
need to go deeper and deeper depending
on kind of what the business is so for
example financial services entities in
most VAT jurisdictions have a really
complex that recovery profile on
purchases and so the Swift
classification logic the PwC
classification logic that is deployed
into the Google ml model enables us to
categorize know just like what you saw
on that entertainment experience to look
at the individual description of the
line on the invoice apply business rules
against that to understand what kind of
expense it is and who's incurring it and
in what cost centre and what department
and then apply categorization logic
which then tags to a GST or v80 result
okay so that's where the that's where
the tax marks really kick in and where
the ml models really really serve as
well
because we can access hundreds of
thousands or millions of
of similar transactions posted by all of
our other clients obviously in a fully
sanitized way to deal with privacy to
then effectively come back out with our
suggested classification and
categorization which is really really
powerful because effectively what we're
now doing is moving away from rules
based tax decisions to model-based tax
decisions you know which is really
exciting so that's the end of the demo
we thought we would then take you
through where we're going to take the
solution over the next couple of years
so the product development roadmap for
the rest of 2019 as we discussed earlier
we finished the proof of concept earlier
this year we've now gone live with this
as a live client solution within
Australia we're very quickly localizing
the solution in additional jurisdictions
this will be our global solution so
we're moving very quickly I'll talk
about those locations in the next slide
and next as I mentioned earlier the API
configuration to expensive management
systems we see as key in the short term
because typically our clients really
struggle with the extraction of data so
being able to have api's into the main
expense management systems including the
SA PSAP Conquer Oracle etc all those
main expense systems will be looking to
configure into their api's and UI
enhancement as pretty as this looks or
did look we're very conscious that
clients do want value-added analytics
and reporting as brady was mentioning
earlier if you think about the expense
classification analysis that we've been
able to do some of our clients have
talked to us about using that for
broader management reporting because a
lot of them don't have visibility
themselves over the different
classifications of expense spend or
potentially miss classifications so
broader use cases are we're looking into
as well so I'll move on to our
localization strategy
sorry just I know these back and forth
poppies and we should have really
prepared it back and forth I apologize
um the one thing I was just going to
was the the API and configuration into
the erps and I kind of touched on it
earlier really really critical for us
because this is one part of a broader
compliance process stream for tax so
we've got calculation in the system and
then that data then moves into reporting
Suites an SI p an oracle in particular
are developing their capability around
tax reporting and filing out of the ERP
as opposed to extraction and then filing
in you know via a third party solution
and so what this is really really
exciting about is this enables
end-to-end automation and PBC actually
is working with SOP as well to build tax
reporting solutions inside of the ERP to
do the the filing to the regulator some
of the you know the post-filing
analytics and reconciliations and
trending and variance testing and so by
having back-end you know backend
automation inside of the ERP to do tax
compliance and reporting combined with
tax calculation at the front end all
inside of the system is a really really
exciting prospect for us and it's an
it's enabled by GCP and google ai and ml
you know through through the
collaboration that you know PVC sop and
google a you know partaking in at the
moment so really really exciting times
sorry
so our localization australia we've
started in australia we're sort of
hitting north west through through the
world
we're localizing for three different
reasons so the strategy is driven by the
complexity of tax rules so we certainly
believe that we should tackle complex
jurisdictions early because if you can
do it in complex jurisdictions you can
do it in anywhere and the EU and Canada
are examples of particularly complex
jurisdictions so those localizations are
already underway the value of tax at
stake clearly our clients want us to
localize where they have the biggest
task tax risk or biggest tax amount
sitting on the table not being collected
so an example of that in us in at the
asia-pac region is Singapore so
Singapore is the hub for
in the region which have a v80 and GST
Hong Kong does not so our Singaporean
based clients are very keen to get this
solution so we're localizing there and
India is an example of where you have
very complex local country validation
rules so the process for claiming tax
credits and invoice on invoices in India
is very complex so we're localizing
there as well so by localizing in those
different countries which have those
different complexities and requirements
we're confident that we will then have a
product which is truly globally capable
based on those first five countries and
certainly we're looking to replicate
what we've already done from global v80
reporting automation for which we've had
a solution in place for a number of
years into this upstream source system
classification validation and
calculation so we'll finish just on
future use cases and I'd be keen to hear
anyone's ideas because it always open to
new ideas our clients were always
challenging us with new ideas so the
obvious one to us is any other tax
applications where the underlying
document is relevant for for tax
classification so here we're talking
about withholding tax stamp taxes sales
taxes if you're having to make an OPEX
versus capex decision which has a tax
impact any of these taxes which rely on
a document for calculation and
validation are prime candidates and our
clients are asking us to build those
more broadly in finance process
automation many of our clients are going
through those cloudy RP upgrades at S
400 upgrades etc and this is the perfect
time for them to do that that last leg
of automation which isn't necessarily
available within those cloud ERP Suites
and thirdly brought a business process
automation I mean the sky's the limit
anything within a business process which
involves someone having to use a
document to make a decision or a
classification or a validation the zip
line can be applied to so what we're
keen to get the core use case bedded
down
and localized across those five
countries but we really see the ability
to have multiple streams and multiple
different use cases of zip line in the
very near future and I think it's useful
to call that in two and three in
particular well in it costs all of those
three use cases with these are real
examples of clients in the very very
early embryonic stages of this project
that are starting to ask us could it do
this could it do that and so we've had
clients ask us about withholding taxes
we've got one client we were actually
doing a an augmentation of this to do
accounts payable processing so to
actually process the expense and replace
the existing process altogether not just
do the tax calc really exciting stuff
particular when you see the cost of
invoice processing which I think we had
on one of our earlier slides and around
five dollars us an invoice the you know
the other thing that we've started to do
is work together with some of our
forensics and analytics teams outside of
tax and we're doing things you know in
terms of complimenting some existing
processes around you know loan document
analysis for banks you know expense
fraud analysis just given that the power
of the data that we've got in this in
this in this model and so yeah really
really you know we see this is as a you
know a little humble indirect tax
solution that has much much greater
application outside of indirect taxes
and huge potential for client through
our clients
[Music]